how can it possibly be right
that the police constable on 27 000
pounds a year should be taxed at 32
pence in the pound
but someone making many times more from
buying and selling shops and stocks and
shares
should pay just 20 pence in the pounds
that will not stand under labour
i pledge
that as chancellor i will not balance
the books on the backs of working people
and
here's our second principle
we will bring a laser focus to
efficiency in our tax system
there are hundreds of different tax
breaks
some are important
but too many simply provide loopholes
for those who can afford the best advice
and added together
they cost more than the entire nhs
budget
so we will look at every single tax
break and if it doesn't deliver for the
economy or for the taxpayer then we will
scrap it
and
and here are a couple
here are a couple that we will scrap
right away
under the conservative party private
equity bosses who asset strip british
businesses pay a lower rate of tax on
their bonuses than their workers do on
their wages that is indefensible we
would scrap it
and here's another
right now
private schools enjoy charitable status
which makes them exempt
both from business rates
and from v80
at a cost to taxpayers
of 1.7 billion pounds every year
but conference
here's the truth
private schools are not charities
and so we will end that exemption and
put that money straight into our state
schools state schools like the one i
went to conference that is what a labour
government will do
and here's our third principle
we will support our high streets
every single high street business
is a labor of love
and a product of courage and of
determination
that gives life to our everyday economy
they have faced huge adversity this last
year and many are struggling right now
with a cliff edge of rates relief coming
up in march
four out of five retail businesses are
warning that they may have to close
outlets if the government does not act
so today we are calling on government to
freeze business rates next year to
increase the threshold for small
business rates relief giving small and
medium-sized businesses in all sectors a
discount next year
and conference
to pay for those measures
the government should increase the
digital services tax to 12
in the next year to make sure online
companies who have thrived during this
pandemic are paying their fair share of
taxes too
but the truth is
our whole system of business taxation is
not fair and it's not fit for purpose
how can it be when bricks and mortar
high street businesses are taxed more
heavily than online giants
high street businesses pay over a third
of business rates despite making up only
15 of our overall economy
but when amazon's revenues went up by
nearly 2 million pounds last year
how much did their taxes go up by less
than one percent
conference
if you can afford to fly to the moon
then you can afford to play your taxes
here on planet earth
so we will level the playing field and
ease the burden on bricks and mortar
businesses
labor will take the bold action needed
to support those businesses and make
sure every community can enjoy a
thriving high street we will oversee the
biggest overhaul of business taxation in
a generation
so i can announce today
that the next labour government will
scrap business rates altogether
and here and here is our guarantee
the system that will replace it will
incentivize investment
promote entrepreneurship reward
businesses that move into empty premises
and no public service or local authority
will lose out from those changes
but most of all
it will make our system of business
taxation fair for the 21st century
together
these principles of taxation
prizing fairness
efficiency and support for business
comprise our approach to funding our
public services
one which will support hard work
enterprise and adaptability
recognizing the value of work
demanding efficiency supporting thriving
high streets conference that is what a
labour government will do
and i want to make one thing abundantly
clear
we cannot have a return
to the failed approach of austerity
it wouldn't deliver growth
and it would be devastating for our
public services
the next labor manifesto will set out a
plan
to raise living standards and
opportunities across britain
but we cannot tolerate waste when it
comes to public spending
especially when it comes to money wasted
on outsourcing companies
so i promise you
i promise you conference that the next
labor government will carry out the
biggest wave of insourcing of public
services in a generation